rochefort merci d'être avec nous ce soir
vous tourne actuellement un film sur
l'autoroute a71 un film qui signé
dominique show soit c'est un jeune
réalisateur et je crois que c'est un
film drôle oui c'est adeline drôle c'est
un jeune réalisateur c'est vrai et c'est
le scénariste du film c'est un film qui
me semble tout à fait excitant et c'est
un scénario que j'aime énormément et
quel genre de personnages interprétés
vous annonce est un agent de la dgse
on l'appelle le moustachu parce que ces
gens là avaient été formés à londres
pendant la guerre alors il était anglo
filet et est revenue à elle des
moustaches et voilà c'est un agent de la
dgse auquel il va arriver
énormément de catastrophe mais c'est un
film dans un lieu presque plus long
comme ça une aire de repos d'autoroute
c'est là où se passe là le principal de
l'action il arrive tellement de
catastrophe à ce pauvre homme que je
pense que ça sera drôle
à force d'être 4